a celebrated artist is using his talents
to spread a message of hope during this
pandemic award-winning illustrator Kadir
Nelson is known for his painting black
American icons who have inspired him now
they include people like dr. Martin
Luther King jr. baseball star Jackie
Robinson and former Congresswoman
shirley Chisholm CBS Sunday mornings Lee
Cowan shows us how Nelson is now taking
inspiration from other heroes normally
takes Kadir Nelson weeks to pay to work
this big this detail is powerful but
this a matter of days because he says
the times demanded it it's a crucial
moment and I need to have a voice and
say something about it and create an
image that will give people hope I call
the painting after the storm after the
storm after the storm it might have been
easier for Nelson to spend the shutdown
looking at the near empty streets of LA
depicting the fear and anxiety the
corona virus is leaving in its wake but
what struck him or was the globe's
resilience and courage eyes up looking
forward he says should be the signatures
of this difficult time
not the grim reality behind us I always
felt that it's more important to portray
the better part of ourselves something
that speaks to something bigger than us
strength is what he captures best this
is his view of congresswoman shirley
Chisholm Aretha Franklin and Harriet
Tubman he's helped resurrect history too
portraying the players in Negro League
baseball and reminding us why Muhammad
Ali mattered so much
I think what's in in my head is is the
the idea or the feeling that I wanted to
have it has to have an emotion yeah yeah
I think that's what makes art
art he should know his art is highly
prized by collectors many hang and
museums and galleries he intends to give
much of the proceeds from the sale of
after the storm to Kovac 19 relief
efforts wherever the money is needed the
most we are all human beings we are we
are all part of the human family and we
are all experiencing this together art
can reflect who we are as a society
let's just hope that Kadir Nelson
depiction he's indeed in Los Angeles Lee
Cowen for CBS this morning
Bravo Kadir Nelson eyes up after the
storm indeed we can't wait till that
happens to all of us moving forward and
if you'd like to see more of that please
please if you'd like to see more of that
piece please go online what they did on
Sunday morning was knockout